Shawn has been tucked away in Malibu
writing his new material which touches
on heartbreak anxiety and vulnerability
gave me something singer/songwriter told
the Elvis Duran show although he's
nervous about releasing his new music he
is ready to let his fans in I just
wanted to come come into this whole
album process with the most harnessed
thing I could possibly do and kind of
just cement to people that I'm gonna be
truthful with my stuff and I think that
it's a big leap you know to kind of just
throw out a single where you're talking
very personal about stuff like this but
I think you know going through the the
tweets and stuff last night I was up to
like 2:00 a.m. just like reading stories
of people saying you know how much
they've connected with this in their own
way and that's the whole reason we write
something Shawn will debut in my blood
live on The Late Late Show with James
Corden March 28th and then oh he'll just
casually be performing for the Queen at
her 92nd birthday bash alongside Kylie
Minogue and Shaggy
I have no idea I mean I'm definitely I
don't know Queen Elizabeth very well the
best part is this is not that I'm
performing it's that shaggy is also
[Music]
performing it wasn't me in front of the
Queen on her that's the question